india's covert 19 death toll has surged
past
200 000 this is one of the highest death
tolls in the world
the numbers are rising fast driven
partly by a
new more infectious variant countries
around the world have begun
sending medical aid to india including
desperately needed oxygen
as the wave of new infections overwhelms
its health care system
hospitals are being forced to turn
patients away as authorities scramble to
get equipment to those
who need it most
in some indian hospitals the oxygen
supply has run out
people who might have survived the
disease are dying as a result
there's no oxygen in all of town
my mother was admitted three days ago i
was told she was fine and recovering
all the tests were done then last night
they said they didn't have any more
oxygen
she passed away
hospitals and icu units across the
country are overwhelmed
after weeks of a sharp rise in cases the
health care system is collapsing
[Music]
oxygen has become the most precious of
commodities
i'm buying oxygen at the rate of gold
you know it has
the situation come to that level
they are lowering the oxygen level
but it needs to be higher so this is the
problem
with oxygen and hospital beds running
out the government is scrambling to get
equipment to the areas that are hardest
hit
we have compressed oxygen that's moving
across the country using
the country's railway system to get it
to the places that need it the most
emergency supplies from the uk have
begun arriving
and more help is promised from abroad
after the final details have been
clarified with the indian side
the first shipment should be on its way
in the next few days
but in the meantime many indians are
left to fend for themselves
doing all they can to care for loved
ones
some drive for hours in search of oxygen
i have come from very far to collect
oxygen from my father
i'm scared that although the oxygen is
available today what will we do if it's
not available
tomorrow but until help arrives on a
larger scale
many people in india are left gasping
for air
for more now i'm joined by tarek
yasarevich he's a spokesperson for the
world health organization
in geneva switzerland thanks for being
with us this morning first of all
we've seen pictures of hospitals in
india being overwhelmed
for days now can you tell us whether or
not the pandemic in india
is peaking or could there still be worse
to come there
well good morning it's very difficult to
predict
how the situation will evolve what is
important really
is that we all support uh health system
in india uh that people
try to protect themselves so they are as
much
safe as possible and that they follow
the advice that is being given
by health authorities as in any country
when you have a sort of a combination of
factors
such as new variants that are likely to
be more transmissible
mass gatherings when the vaccination
levels are low and people are relaxing
their
personal protective behavior we can see
this sort of explosion although we have
not seen in any
other country on this scale we need
really to stand with the
uh with india now and try to help as
much as we can
what role are the new virus
variants that we're hearing about in
india playing
in the pandemic there
well viruses are changing and this is
normal we
at who we are following and monitoring
these
changes that occur as the virus
transmits
uh from population to population
uh we have identified already uh
free variants that have been uh first
seen
in uh in brazil in south africa and uk
that are more likely to be transmissible
uh uh in a a in a faster way than the
original one so there is a new one that
has been identified in india
preliminary studies are ongoing we need
to understand
more but it seems uh that this variant
as well has the capacity and potential
to attach to human cells more easily
that would obviously
meaning more people being infected and
that would lead to more hospitalizations
and more debts what we need to know is
really try to
contain as much as possible this
transmission
okay uh making sure that people who are
uh sick follow their advice do not
necessarily go to hospital
but take care at home when possible try
to isolate
um here uh government is trying
to provide the right information to
hotline
uh there is also consideration of having
community screening right
uh center uh providing information to
know where
uh beds are available in rich areas
of course what about the oxygen
situation in india
does the country have enough medical
oxygen or are oxygen supplies just not
getting through to the areas that need
it quickly enough
well there are reports of shortages of
oxygen
from different parts of india the
government is stepping up
trying to increase the production of
oxygen
in different parts of the country
they're also using their air force
to try to to to dispatch supplies where
needed
as you have already said in your program
that there is also international
mobilization
who uh is uh uh uh is providing uh
4 000 oxygen concentrators
uh us has already committed to provide
ten thousand
and first of those have already arrived
other countries
uh like singapore russia saudi arabia
have also uh have also started
as well as european union uh started to
to to to to mobilize support for india
it is it is important to say that uh in
the absence
of of of drugs for covet 19 we have only
one that has been
uh uh recommended so far this that's a
cocktail steroids and dexamethasone
the oxygen is a life-saving commodity
and we hope that these shortages will be
overcome soon
mr yasarevic thank you very much for
talking with us that was tariq
yasarevich from the world health
organization
in geneva delhi bureau chief
marita chima is following this story
closely of course and joins us now good
to see you amrita
the healthcare system across india seems
to be overwhelmed are people even
trying to reach hospitals anymore to get
treatment
absolutely terry those people who are
critically ill
are being rushed to hospitals by their
relatives and sometimes with very
disappointing results
because they find the doors of the
hospital shut
because they have no more capacity to
take people
the number of cases particularly a city
like delhi have been
so high that the whole medical
infrastructure is being put under
huge strain we got a glimpse of that in
your report
people are not running short of oxygen
they now they're running short of beds
medical staff find short supply because
half of the wards are kobe tested
i have tested positive for kovid
critical equipment
is not there so people are sometimes
just left hanging
waiting outside hospitals languishing on
footpaths waiting for medical attention
and we've seen some harrowing stories
about people just
losing their lives waiting for someone
to come and
give them help now this is taking a huge
toll uh on people here including doctors
now i've seen doctors
in middle of interviews break down and
cry and one doctor said
people are coming here and look to me
for help and i have to just watch
them die i am so helpless you mentioned
a lack of critical equipment
that applies also to oxygen supplies
there have been reports of oxygen and
essential medications being sold on the
black market
at hugely inflated prices is this
problem
being tackled by authorities
certainly when the need is so great uh
terry of course
a black market has sprung up especially
for oxygen but also for drugs for
ventilators
and authorities have cracked down and
taken
some hoarders into custody but
as i said people are desperate and when
they are so desperate they find a way
around to get this critical equipment
that they want for their loved ones
and are prepared to pay any price as we
heard in this report
i mean oxygen is the price of gold so
yes
um but we have some international aid
coming in that's given a big
psychological boost
to india as a nation um they see that
the world
is watching the world wants to help but
that aid has not yet trickled down
on the ground to people who need it most
the true
number of deaths from covet 19 in india
is rumored to be much higher than
officially recorded
why do you think that is amrita
you know it's difficult to say uh um
terry i mean
national and local media is talking
about the death toll being about five to
ten times more than the official death
toll
and the official death toll is pretty
high as it is part of the reason is that
in fact many of the people
who have uh died they've not been
officially
covered positive tested that's because a
laboratory are under huge pressure
and they're not able to test everyone
who is sick so these people have been
not
part of the official provide death toll
yet they are
we are seeing images coming from
crematorium they're seeing images coming
from burial grounds
and the numbers of bodies that are
coming in is quite
unprecedented in fact one of the other
indication is that they're running out
of ambulances to take bodies to
cremation guns and burial grounds and
there was this
heartbreaking image of a man in a
private car with a body strapped on his
roof
heading down the street ostensibly to a
burial ground or a cremation ground
simply because he could find an
ambulance to take his loved one there
horrific scenes uh i'm rita thank you
very much that was our delhi bureau
chief amrita chima
let's catch up on some of the other
developments in the pandemic worldwide
brazil's senate has opened an inquiry
into whether president
giardio bolsonaro's government committed
criminal negligence or corruption
in its handling of the pandemic south
korea hopes to encourage more people to
get vaccinated by exempting those who've
been inoculated from quarantine measures
currently anyone who's been in contact
with a confirmed patient or
returned from overseas travel must
undergo 14 days
of quarantine and the netherlands is
lifting several coronavirus restrictions
that have been in place since january
including
a nighttime curfew